qui meurent avant l'âge de 5 ans.
Il s'agit réellement
d'un succès phénoménal
qui est peu connu,
c'est que l'on fait des progrès incroyables.
Nous passons de 20 millions d'enfants
peu après que je sois né
à environ 6 millions.
C'est une histoire
de vaccins, principalement.
La variole tuait 2 millions d'enfants par an.
Elle a été éradiquée. Ce nombre est descendu à 0.
La rougeole tuait 2 millions d'enfants par an, descendue à quelques 100.000.
C'est une courbe
où vous voulez voir ce nombre encore diminuer,
et ça sera possible
en utilisant la science, en donnant les nouveaux vaccins aux enfants.
Nous pouvons accélérer le progrès.
Pendant les 10 dernières années,
ce nombre a chuté plus vite que jamais
dans toute l'histoire.
J'aime le fait que vous puissiez dire,
ok, si nous pouvons inventer de nouveaux vaccins
si nous pouvons les acheminer,
utiliser nos dernières connaissances dans ce domaine,
si nous délivrons comme il faut, nous pouvons faire des miracles.
CA : Vous avez fait le calcul, et ça marche: littéralement,
des milliers d'enfants sont sauvés chaque année
comparé à l'année précédente.
On n'en parle pas.
Un crash d'avion qui fait 200 morts
est une histoire de loin bien plus médiatisée.
Est-ce que ça vous rend fou ?
BG : Oui, car tout cela intervient dans le silence.
Il s'agit d'un enfant, un enfant à chaque fois.
98% de tout cela
n'est pas lié aux catastrophes naturelles.
Mais les donations pour les catastrophes naturelles sont énormes.
C'est incroyable, comment les gens pensent
"ça pourrait être moi", et l'argent coule.
Ces causes sont un peu invisibles.
Avec les objectifs du Millénaire pour le développement
et de nombreux projets,
nous assistons à une générosité accrue.
Le but est de descendre ce chiffre en dessous du million,
ce qui devrait être possible de notre vivant.
CA : Peut-être qu'il fallait quelqu'un enthousiasmé par les chiffres
au lieu d'un grand visage triste
pour s'engager là-dedans.
Vous l'avez écrit dans votre lettre,
vous avez utilisé cet argument pour dire que l'aide d'urgence,
contrairement à la pensée selon laquelle elle serait inutile et inefficace,
est en fait efficace.
BG : Oui, par exemple,
il y a eu des aides d'urgences bien intentionnées
qui se sont mal passées.
Il y a eu des investissements de capital-risque
qui étaient bien intentionnés et qui ont mal tourné.
Vous ne devriez pas simplement dire, ok, à cause de ça,
parce que le bilan n'est pas parfait,
ça ne fonctionne pas.
Demandez-vous plutôt : quel est votre but ?
Comment essayez-vous d'améliorer la nutrition,
la survie, et l'alphabétisation afin que ces pays puissent être autonomes,
qu'ils puissent dire que les choses vont bien et s'améliorent ?
Nous pouvons mieux organiser l'aide d'urgence.
Ce n'est pas une panacée.
Nous pouvons faire mieux que le capital-risque, je pense,
comme des grandes réussites comme celle-ci.
CA : La sagesse traditionnelle dit
qu'il est assez dur pour des couples mariés de travailler ensemble.
Comment avez-vous réussi ?
MG : Beaucoup de femmes m'ont dit :
« Je ne saurais pas travailler avec mon mari.
Ça ne pourrait pas marcher. »
Vous savez, nous apprécions ça,
cette fondation a été une bonne chose pour nous deux
dans ce parcours d'apprentissage continuel.
Nous ne voyageons pas tant que cela ensemble pour la fondation
comme nous en avions l'habitude lorsque Bill travaillait à Microsoft.
Nous faisons plus de voyages séparément,
mais je sais toujours que lorsque je rentre,
Bill sera intéressé par ce que j'ai appris,
que ce soit sur les femmes, les filles,
ou sur la chaîne d'approvisionnement de vaccins,
ou sur un grand dirigeant.
Il va écouter et sera très intéressé.
Et il sait, lorsqu'il rentre,
même si c'est pour parler de son discours, ou des données, ou de ce qu'il a appris,
que je suis réellement intéressée,
et je pense que nous avons une relation très collaborative.
Mais nous ne passons pas chaque minute ensemble, c'est sûr.
(Rires)
CA : Mais là c'est le cas, et nous en sommes heureux.
Melinda, au début, vous étiez principalement
celle qui menait la danse.
Il y a six ans, il me semble,
Bill est arrivé, il quitté Microsoft, et a travaillé à plein temps.
Ça a dû être dur, de s'ajuster à ça, non ?
MG : Oui. Je pense qu'en fait,
pour les employés de la fondation,
l'angoisse était bien plus grande que pour moi
à propos de l'arrivée de Bill.
Moi, j'étais très excitée.
Bill avait pris la décision,
avant même qu'il ne l'annonce en 2006,
et c'était vraiment sa décision.
Mais c'était en vacances sur la plage
lors de notre promenade,
qu'il avait commencé à y penser.
Pour moi, l'excitation de Bill
pour mettre son cerveau et son coeur à contribution
contre d'immenses problèmes mondiaux,
ces inégalités, c'était passionnant.
Oui, les employés de la fondation angoissaient un peu.
(Applaudissements)
CA : C'est super.
MG: Mais c'était fini dans les 3 mois, dès qu'il était là.
BG : Y compris quelques employés.
MG : Oui, pour les employés,
c'était fini trois mois après ton arrivée.
BG : Je plaisante. MG : Oh, les employés ne sont pas partis.
BG : Quelques-uns sont partis, mais--
(Rires)
CA : Sur quoi vous disputez-vous ?
Le dimanche à 11h du matin,
vous êtes loin du travail,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Quelle est la dispute ?
BG : Parce qu'on a créé tout cela ensemble depuis le début,
c'est un grand partenariat.
J'avais la même relation avec Paul Allen
dans les premiers temps de Microsoft.
Tout comme avec Steve Ballmer lorsque Microsoft se développait,
et maintenant, Melinda, de façon encore plus forte
est également une partenaire.
Alors nous parlons des causes
que nous devrions plus aider,
et de quels groupes travaillent bien.
Elle y voit très clair. Elle s’assoit souvent avec les employés.
Nous faisons les voyages qu'elle a décrits.
Il y a donc beaucoup de collaboration.
Je n'arrive pas à penser à un moment où l'un de nous
avait une opinion tranchée
sur une chose ou une autre.
CA : Et vous Melinda, vous y arrivez ? (Rires)
On ne sait jamais.
MG : Nous abordons les choses sous différents angles,
et je pense que c'est vraiment bien.
Bill peut regarder les données
et dire : « Je veux agir selon ces statistiques générales. »
Moi, j'aborde les choses avec intuition.
Je rencontre beaucoup de personnes sur le terrain.
Bill m'a appris à confronter cette réalité
avec les données globales pour voir si elles collent.
Je pense lui avoir appris à confronter les données
avec les gens sur le terrain pour savoir, peut-on vraiment distribuer ce vaccin ?
Une femme peut-elle accepter ces goûtes pour la polio
dans la bouche de son enfant ?
Parce que le produit fini est aussi important que la science sous-jacente.
Donc je pense qu'avec le temps nous avons composé avec le point de vue de l'autre,
et franchement, le travail est meilleur grâce à cela.
CA : Pour les vaccins, la polio, et ainsi de suite,
vous avez rencontré beaucoup de succès.
Qu'en est-il de l'échec ?
Peut-on parler d'un échec
et peut-être de ce que vous en avez appris ?
BG : Oui. Heureusement, nous pouvons nous en permettre,
parce qu'on en a certainement eu beaucoup.
Nous travaillons beaucoup sur des médicaments et des vaccins
qui échoueront de différentes façons, nous le savons.
Un projet qui a reçu beaucoup d'attention devait concevoir un meilleur préservatif.
Nous avons eu des centaines d'idées.
Peut-être que quelques-unes d'entre elles marcheront.
Nous étions très crédules, en tout cas moi, sur un médicament
pour une maladie en Inde, la leishmaniose viscérale.
Je pensais que dès qu'on aurait le médicament, on éradiquerait la maladie.
Il s'avère qu'il fallait une injection
tous les jours pendant 10 jours.
Cela a pris 3 années de plus que prévues,
et ensuite il n'y avait pas de moyen de l'administrer efficacement.
Heureusement, nous avons découvert que si vous tuez les phlébotomes,
vous pouvez probablement réussir;
Mais nous avons passé 5 ans,
pour ainsi dire, gâché 5 ans,
et environ 60 millions de dollars,
sur une voie qui s'est révélée
très modeste en résultats une fois arrivés au bout.
CA : Vous dépensez un milliard de dollars par an
dans l'éducation, il me semble, quelque chose comme ça.
L'histoire qui s'opère dans ce domaine
est assez longue et complexe.
Y a-t-il des échecs dont vous pouvez parler ?
MG : Une grande leçon pour nous, est que nous pensions au début
que ces petites écoles étaient la réponse.
Les petites écoles aident vraiment. Le taux d'abandon scolaire est bas.
Il y a moins de violence et de délits.
Mais ce que l'on a appris de ce travail,
et ce qui s'est avéré être la clé fondamentale,
c'est le rôle d'un bon enseignant dans la classe.
Faute d'enseignant efficace au devant de la salle de classe,
que l'établissement soit grand ou petit,
vous ne changerez pas la trajectoire
qui rendra cet étudiant prêt pour les études supérieures.
(Applaudissements)
CA : Melinda, c'est vous et Jenn,
votre fille aînée.
C'était il y a 3 semaines, je crois,
3 ou 4 semaines. Où était-ce ?
MG : Nous sommes allées en Tanzanie.
Jenn y est allée.
Tous nos enfants ont beaucoup voyagé en Afrique, en fait.
Nous avons fait quelque chose de différent.
Nous avons décidé de passer
deux nuits et trois jours avec une famille.
Anna et Sanare sont les parents.
Ils nous ont invitées à venir et à rester dans leur maison.
En fait, les chèvres vivaient dans cette petite hutte,
dans leur petit enclos, avant notre arrivée.
Nous sommes restées avec leur famille,
et nous avons vraiment appris
ce à quoi ressemble la vie rurale en Tanzanie.
La différence entre simplement
visiter une demie journée
ou les trois-quarts d'une journée
et rester jour et nuit était profonde,
laissez-moi vous en donner une explication.
Ils avaient six enfants, et en parlant à Anna
dans la hutte de cuisine -- nous y avions passé 5 heures ce jour-là,
elle me disait qu'elle avait prévu et espacé avec son mari
les naissances de leurs enfants.
C'était une relation très tendre.
C'était un guerrier Maasaï et sa femme,
mais ils avaient décidé de se marier.
Il se respectaient et s'aimaient visiblement.
Leurs six enfants,
deux d'entre eux étaient des jumeaux de 13 ans,
un garçon, et une fille nommée Grace.
Lorsque nous allions couper du bois,
En faisant les choses que Grace et sa mère faisaient,
Grace n'était pas une enfant, c'était une adolescente,
mais ce n'était pas une adulte.
Elle était très, très timide.
Elle voulait me parler ainsi qu'à Jenn.
Nous essayions de la faire participer, mais elle était timide.
Une nuit, cependant,
quand toutes les lumières s'éteignaient sur la Tanzanie rurale,
c'était une nuit sans Lune,
la première nuit, et sans étoiles,
Jenn est sortie de notre hutte
avec sa petite lampe frontale,
Grace est immédiatement allée
chercher le traducteur,
elle est allée voir Jenn, et lui a dit :
« Quand tu rentres chez toi, puis-je avoir ta lampe frontale pour étudier la nuit ? »
CA : Oh, waouh.
MG : Son père m'avait dit
qu'il avait peur que, contrairement à son fils,
qui venait de passer son baccalauréat,
à cause de ses tâches ménagères,
elle ne réussissait pas si bien et elle n'était pas encore à l'école publique.
Il m'a dit : « Je ne sais pas comment payer pour son éducation.
Je ne peux pas payer l'école privée.
Elle risque de finir dans cette ferme comme ma femme. »
Ils connaissent la différence qu'une éducation peut avoir
de façon importante et profonde.
CA : Voici une autre photo
de vos deux autres enfants, Rory et Phoebe,
avec Paul Farmer.
Élever trois enfants
lorsque vous êtes la famille la plus riche au monde
semble être une expérience sociale
sans précédent.
Comment avez-vous fait ?
Quelle a été votre approche ?
BG : Je dirais que dans l'ensemble
les enfants ont une bonne éducation
mais vous devez leur donner un sens de leur propre faculté
et de ce qu'ils vont faire.
Notre philosophie est d'être très clair avec eux --
la majorité de l'argent part dans la fondation --
et nous les aidons à trouver quelque chose qui les passionne.
Nous voulons trouver un juste équilibre
où ils ont la liberté de tout faire
mais pas avec beaucoup d'argent,
afin qu'ils ne finissent pas par rien faire.
Jusqu'à maintenant, ils ont été plutôt diligents,
et excités de choisir leur propre voie.
CA : Vous avez soigneusement préservé leur vie privée pour des raisons évidentes.
Je suis curieux de savoir pourquoi vous m'avez donné la permission
de montrer cette photo ici et maintenant à TED.
MG : C'est intéressant.
Alors qu'ils grandissent, ils savent
que la croyance de notre famille, c'est la responsabilité,
que nous avons une chance incroyable
simplement de vivre aux Etats-Unis
et d'avoir une très bonne éducation.
Nous avons la responsabilité de redonner au monde.
Donc, en grandissant, nous leur apprenons --
ils ont voyagé dans tellement de pays à travers le monde --
ils disent : « Nous voulons que les gens sachent que nous croyons
en ce que vous faites, Maman et Papa,
et on est d'accord pour être plus exposés. »
Nous avons donc leur permission de montrer cette photo,
Paul Farmer va probablement
la faire figurer dans un de ses travaux.
Ils s'intéressent profondément
à la mission de la fondation, eux aussi.
CA : Vous avez facilement assez d'argent,
malgré vos importantes donations à la fondation,
pour en faire des millionnaires.
C'est ce que vous voulez pour eux ?
BG : Non. Non. Ça ne se passera pas comme ça.
Ils doivent avoir la notion
que leur propre travail a du sens et est important.
Nous avions lu un long article avant de nous marier,
où Warren Buffett parlait de cela,
et nous sommes convaincus que ce n'est ni un service
pour la société, ni pour les enfants.
CA : En parlant de Warren Buffett,
quelque chose d'extraordinaire est arrivé en 2006,
lorsque votre seul rival en termes de personne la plus riche d'Amérique
a soudainement décidé de donner
80% de sa fortune
à votre fondation.
Comment cela a bien pu arriver ?
Il y a sans doute une version longue et une courte. Donnez-nous plutôt la courte.
BG : Très bien. Warren était un ami proche,
et il allait laisser sa femme Suzie
donner tout l'argent.
Malheureusement, elle est décédée avant lui.
Il est bon en délégation, et
-- (Rires) --
il a dit --
CA : Il faut tweeter ça.
BG : S'il a quelqu'un qui fait quelque chose de bien,
et est prêt à le faire gratuitement,
c'est peut-être d'accord. Mais nous étions stupéfaits.
MG : Entièrement stupéfaits. BG : Nous ne nous y attendions pas.
Ce fut incroyable.
Ça nous a aidé à élever notre ambition
dans ce que la fondation peut faire de façon considérable.
La moitié de nos ressources
provient de la générosité époustouflante de Warren.
CA : Je crois que vous vous êtes engagés, avant la fin de vos activités,
à ce que 95% ou plus de votre fortune aille à la fondation.
BG : Oui.
CA : Comme cette relation, c'est incroyable --
(Applaudissements)
Récemment, vous et Warren
avez essayé de persuader
d'autres milliardaires et gens riches
de s'engager à donner
plus de la moitié de leurs actifs à la philanthropie.
Commence cela se passe-t-il ?
BG : Nous avons environ 120 personnes
qui s'y sont maintenant engagés.
Ce qui est génial, c'est que nous nous rencontrons
tous les ans et nous discutons -
embauchez-vous, combien vous payez ?
Nous n'essayons pas d'homogénéiser tout ça.
La beauté de la philanthropie vient de cette superbe diversité.
Les gens donnent à des causes.
Nous regardons et nous disons « woaouh ».
Mais c'est génial.
Le rôle de la philanthropie
est de choisir différentes approches,
y compris dans un seul domaine, comme l'éducation.
Nous avons besoin de plus d'expérimentations.
Mais c'est fabuleux, de rencontrer ces gens,
de partager leur parcours vers la philanthropie,
comment ils impliquent leurs enfants, ce qu'ils font de différent.
Le succès est bien plus grand que ce que l'on croit.
On dirait que cela va juste continuer à prendre de l'ampleur
dans les années à venir.
MG : Faire en sorte que les gens voient que d'autres personnes
apportent le changement avec la philanthropie --
ce sont des gens qui ont créé leurs propres entreprises,
qui ont mis leur ingéniosité dans des idées incroyables.
S'ils mettent leur idées et leur cerveau
au service de la philanthropie, ils peuvent changer le monde.
Ils commencent à voir d'autres personnes y parvenir, et il disent :
« Waouh, je veux faire ça avec mon argent. »
Pour moi, c'est vraiment ce qui est incroyable.
CA : J'ai l'impression qu'il est assez dur
pour certaines personnes de trouver
comment dépenser autant d'argent
dans quelque chose d'autre.
Il y a probablement des milliardaires dans la salle
et certainement des gens qui ont réussi.
Je suis curieux, pouvez-vous leur tenir votre discours ?
Quel est le discours ?
BG : C'est la chose la plus satisfaisante que nous ayons fait,
et ça ne vous appartient pas,
si ce n'est pas bon pour vos enfants,
réunissons-nous pour en parler
et voir ce que nous pouvons faire.
Le monde est bien meilleur
grâce aux philanthropes du passé.
La tradition américaine, qui est la plus forte, attire la convoitise du monde entier.
Si je suis si optimiste,
c'est parce que je pense que la philanthropie
va se développer
et s'occupera de ces choses
où les gouvernements ne sont pas efficaces
pour faire briller la lumière dans la bonne direction.
CA : Il y a cette inégalité terrible dans le monde,
une inégalité accrue
qui semble structurelle.
Il me semble que si davantage de vos semblables
prenaient l'approche que vous avez prise,
cela créerait une brèche
à la fois dans ce problème
et dans la perception de ce problème.
Est-ce un commentaire juste ?
BG : Oh, oui. Si vous prenez aux plus riches
et donnez aux moins riches, c'est bien.
On essaie d'avoir un équilibre, et c'est bien.
MG : Mais vous changez les systèmes.
Aux Etats-Unis, nous essayons de réformer le système éducatif
afin qu'il soit juste pour tout le monde
et qu'il fonctionne pour tous les élèves.
Cela, pour moi, change réellement
la balance inégalitaire.
BG : C'est le plus important.
(Applaudissements)
CA : Je pense vraiment que la plupart des gens ici
et plusieurs millions à travers le monde
sont juste en admiration de la trajectoire
que vos vies ont prises
et de l'angle spectaculaire
avec lequel vous façonnez le futur.
Merci beaucoup d'être venus à TED,
et merci pour tout ce que vous faites.
BG : Merci. MG : Merci.
(Applaudissements)
BG : Merci. MG : Merci beaucoup.
BG : Parfait, bravo. (Applaudissements)